while some posters are designed to look
flashy or show off how many a-list
actors can fit into a 27 by 41 inch
sheet of paper there are those rare few
that aspire to do something more the
following incredible posters are crammed
full of subtext and hidden references
that you may have never noticed Logan if
there's one thing Logan doesn't but
secretly does want you to know it's that
it's not your average superhero movie it
hides this behind a western themed
poster that references an era of slow
burn and morally weighted films that
have long since passed Logan is a story
just as much about superhuman powers as
it is the gritty reality of these poor
characters which makes a movie that much
more similar to its posters genre
archetype that a superhero adventure
it's a poster that's a bit on the nose
with its message but hides the true
extent of its meaning until after you've
walked out of the theater as above so
below riffing off its title the poster
for as above so below depicts an
upside-down Eiffel Tower that's pointed
in the direction of hell
but what if in fact it's not pointing
towards hell but it's actually
representing Hell itself
maybe the Eiffel Tower is actually
mirrored to represent the fact that
we're all living in Hell right now
the image features a tunnel built of
human skulls using human agony as a
building block for urban planning
perhaps supposed to is sane that the
earth we inherited and continually
corrupt has become our own worst
nightmare for Ragnarok of all the films
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe Thor
Ragnarok has one of the most
impressively designed posters featuring
colors galore a dope retro aesthetic and
some very cool portrayals of the lead
characters you might be wondering how
can his Singh get any better the answer
is simple a hidden reference to historic
Norse mythology also known as the entire
basis for Thor's movies those big
colorful rings are surrounding the
characters are a direct nod to Norse
mythology Stein realms and the Tree of
Life the latter of which is represented
by Thor himself and in a way the message
the poster is trying to convey is true
Thor as the central component in this
entire universe Kong the Skull Island
if you thought making King Kong look as
intimidating as possible was as post as
only merits think again the design is
particularly old score calling
not only to the days of the Vietnam War
but also to the movies centered around
it specifically scale Islands poster
riffs on Apocalypse Now the Vietnam
focused Francis Ford Coppola classic
that featured an extremely similar
aesthetic for his promotional art from
the stylized funk to the helicopters
ripping across a blood red sunset congas
going 1 for 1 with its inspiration in
terms of throwback accuracy a cure for
wellness if the title alone sends chills
down your spine the poster for a cure
for wellness only serves to reinforce
our fear anyone who searches for
something too good would invariably end
up finding something bad the poster
warns displaying a cure that's actually
modeled after a victorian-era poison
vial this is representative of the
movie's general theme that no matter how
noble the goal trying something evil in
the quest for progress will always
result in pain for everyone involved The
Silence of the Lambs it's no accident
that the Silence of the Lambs poster is
absolutely iconic this expert piece of
subliminal messaging was crafted to show
just how ominous the movie is why is
Clarice's skin so pale
to prepare audiences for the abundance
of lifelessness ahead and that creepy
death's-head hawkmoth covering her mouth
it's symbolic of the transformation
Clarice must go through to conquer her
foes similar to the moth in the movie
itself which transforms with in a cocoon
that's been stuffed inside the mouth of
one of buffalo bill's victims speaking
of those victims look a little closer in
your see that a skull on the Mossback
isn't actually a skull at all it's
actually made of women a reference to a
famous Salvador Dali photograph not to
mention foreshadowing of Buffalo Bills
crimes and Hannibal Lecter's
sophistication and depravity and that
same freaky mouth covering her mouth
alludes to you guessed it the Silence of
the Lamb
also known as Clarice herself
[Music]
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love tea
[Music]